hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round nine of this year's
Tata steel Chess Masters it is panand
the versus juun and both of them are
having a very nice event Prague even
more so he started off by drawing three
games then he defeated world champion
Ding luren and then again for draws and
now uh he faces juun uh women's world
champion who uh also has an interesting
event she did lose two games but she did
defeat ala fuja so let's check it out
it's quite an interesting game features
uh one of your favorite openings the
Knight attack to the to two Knight's
defense so let's dive straight into it
and we are going to explore many many
lines as this is quite a complicated
game so Prague has the white pieces
opens with E4 as advertised we have the
two Knight defense Knight to C6 Bishop
to C4 and now Knight to F6 the two
Knight defens is on the board and now
not the main move D3 but rather Knight
to G5 the Knight attack to the uh to the
two knights defense and now Pawn to D5
this is the only move that works and
it's the only move that has been played
since Knight to G5 was first played so
Pawn to D5 otherwise how are you
defending the F7 Pawn that's the only
way to do it we have e captures on D5
and now Knight to A5 attacking the
bishop I don't know if you guys remember
I did mention that Story I played in a
tournament some three or four years ago
here in my hometown and I played against
uh I don't know maybe the the the boy
was 8 years old or maybe nine maybe 10 I
don't really remember uh but here after
this e captures and D5 move he played
Pawn to B5 and I've never seen this move
in my life I was so weirded out by this
I was like okay he probably doesn't know
how to play chess very well but then you
know it's it's I figured out it's U it's
quite an interesting move and I'm going
to show you what happens here in case
you also run into such a such a little
boy now I played Bishop captures on B5
which is not the best move in the end I
was able to win the game but it um
really took me a lot moves to get into a
better position uh the way you play this
is Bishop to F1 and this is the only way
to uh sort of push for Advantage with
white and then after Queen captures you
develop Knight C3 attack the queen and
the B5 pawn and only after the queen
moves you bring the bishop back Bishop
captur some B5 because you had to defend
that G2 pawn and now after let's say
Bishop E7 you will play D3 uh and after
both players Castle let's say castles
castles you will play Knight to D or
rather black will play Knight to D4 go
after the bishop you will go Bishop to
C4 and now Bishop to B7 grabs hold of
this diagonal let's see Rook D1 and if
Checkmate is being threatened it's okay
to play F3 uh so this is uh you know in
general just so you know how to handle
this B5 U idea but I played Bishop
captures and B5 and then soon after
Queen captures on D5 it's not uh clear
what to do with the bishop you no longer
have time for Bishop to F1 as the E4 is
coming then the Knight will be hanging
and it's a pretty pretty tricky
situation you will have to capture on C
six and already it's not that impressive
it's an open game your opponent will
have the bishop pair so not the best uh
but in the game they went for the
classical approach Knight to A5 we have
Bishop to B5 check C6 D captures B
captures and now not Bishop to E2 the
move I enjoy playing and that I have
played so many times in my rapid games
online but Bishop to
D3 that's sort of a fancy way of playing
this opening and it's been used quite a
lot in modern times uh I think um even
Alex say shirov played against Magnus
Carlson and potentially won one of the
or maybe even won two games against
Magnus not sure we'll have to look that
up uh but it's a very playable move and
Knight to D5 this is the main reply
against this bishop to D3 line uh just
keeps everything solid also it makes
sense that there's no way for white to
advance the pawn to D4 or D3 the bishop
is on D3 uh and the Knight is hanging so
of course you have to figure out what to
do about this and Knight to F3 is the
main move but PR goes Pawn to H4 and uh
he's sort of Daring du engine to to play
Pawn to H6 and it's um the absolute best
move recommended by the engine but it's
not an easy one to play if you don't
know your ins and outs uh otherwise
you're just going to get um you're going
to get uh destroyed here to give you an
example if H6 yeah of course Prague will
play Queen to H5 now threatened
Checkmate and also you cannot capture
the Knight because the Rook would hang
and then after Queen to F6 you would
have some options here uh you could all
go for let's say Knight to E4 and we
could even see a repetition here with
something like Queen F6 Knight E4 but
most likely as I don't think Prague
would settle for a draw so early with
the white pieces we would see something
like Knight to H7 uh Knight captures and
F7 doesn't work uh because of course you
will not take with the queen you will
play Knight to F4 and you will attack
the White Queen and the bishop here and
then black is just better uh so probably
you know Knight to H7 would be played
here and then after Rook captures on H7
and Bishop captures you will trap the
the bishop with G6 but still you have to
win the bishop uh in in a proper manner
uh and it's very easy to make a mistake
to give you an example if Queen E2
already black makes sort of an
inaccuracy something like Knight to F4
let's say queen to F3 and queen to G7
going after the bishop already Queen to
C3 is winning for white there is not a
good way to uh to win that Bishop H5 is
coming and uh you don't even have to
capture the Knight right away you can
first capture the pawn with check if the
queen captures Bishop then capture the
Knight and white will just always be
better uh capturing on G2 with check
King F1 doesn't really do any all that
much for for black uh but okay after H4
we have Queen to C7 and now Pawn to B3
uh you could also go for Bishop captures
on H7 and this is still a known position
Bishop captures on H7 is one of the
moves that has been played here also
some other moves are castles and you
could continue to maybe develop with
Knight to C3 I can even show you this uh
also a very interesting line uh we're
going to trap the bishop but now H5 and
after Queen t7 going after the Knight D3
uh defending the Knight now Knight F4
blocking the bishop so Bishop will
capture captures with check and I just
Queen E2 offering a queen trade so King
D7 avoiding the queen trade now you are
still hoping to capture the Knight here
now Queen captures on E7 Bishop captures
Knight captures attacking The Rook Rook
captures on H7 and Knight to E5 check
King to C7 captures on G6 and you will
have this position where white is up
four pawns but down a piece and this
it's a really open game still the bishop
per is on the board uh black is probably
still better but
um uh prag probably you know figures
that if she doesn't know everything by
heart that is going to be very very hard
to to reach this uh and she will have to
spend U an incredible amount of time
going into this but uh he goes Pawn to
B3 instead and it is now as of move 10er
we have a completely new game so he he
didn't want to risk it with something
like Bishop captures he thought that she
would calculate well and he just uh
tries something that has never been
tried before and it looks like a very
slow approach because now you definitely
can go after the Knight but still it's
very very complicated H6 goes after the
Knight and now you don't have time for
Queen to H5 because the queen on C7
already guards Checkmate uh so he would
just be um a blunder like Queen H5
Knight to F4 and you can already resign
this the queen moves even just H
captures and G5 wins the game so instead
after this um H6 we have Knight back to
E4 by Prague and now Pawn to F5 going
after the Knight again Knight E to C3
and now she goes back Knight to F6 uh
another way to to make it interesting is
Knight to F4 and then let's say if
Bishop F1 guarding the pawn here you go
Bishop to B7 and now if G3 attacking the
Knight you can even play C5 and attack
The Rook on H1 and if Rook H2 okay now
you either move the Knight or you can
even Castle Queens side here and you
will really have an interesting game
here since absolutely everything uh is
hanging here if for example you capture
he captures on F4 also opens up the E
file uh doesn't look very good for white
but she goes back Knight to F6 and now
Bishop to B2 by Prague just continuing
development uh Bishop to D6 we have
Knight to A3 now uh trying to get that
Knight to some active squares like
Knight to C4 and now Pawn to E4 grabbing
more space here pushing the bishop back
Queen to E2 first preventing the capture
of the bishop while developing a piece
and now Castles by Jun and prag goes
Bishop to A6 he wants to trade off the
light Square Bishops and the idea is
that um well you should definitely
capture Bishop captures an A6 something
like Queen captures and Knight G4 looks
really nice for Jun puts pressure on the
king side it's very hard to Castle Queen
side for prago so F2 would hang and uh
it's possible you know to even see a
repetition here like Rook F1 Knight to
H2 Rook Rook back somewhere Knight back
to G4 and so on and even if you see
something like Knight to C4 let's say
Knight captures Queen captures King to
H7 uh you still have to deal with this
F2 pawn and probably probably Prague
would not go for a repetition but um uh
well it it would be interesting to see
what uh what he would do here uh because
objectively it is better to just go for
the for the repetition but okay uh in
the game Bishop to E6 was played and uh
the game continues Knight to C4 for
Prague uh Bishop to B4 and now Prague
does get the castle Queen side as he
doesn't have to worry about the king
side pawns uh Knight to B7 uh thinking
about REM maneuvering the Knight to D6
but prog now does something that you
wouldn't expect in an open position H he
gives up the bishop for Knight Bishop
captures on B7 Queen captures and just
plays Pawn to F3 uh hinting at uh well
just um strong positional play but also
maybe you want to just bust open the
king side here uh Rook a to E8 uh going
after that Queen on E2 and now just
Knight to
E5 uh so what do you play here well it's
a really really tricky position where it
seems like you could maybe do something
about this Knight not being defended
like Bishop captures on B3 H but it
doesn't work because after a captures
and Rook captures on E5 Now The Rook is
the victim of a nasty Discovery Knight
captures on e4 also attacks the rook and
once you move the Rook now Knight
captures on F7 on F6 with check if you
don't want to give up a material for
nothing you will have to play G captures
and now look at this queen to C4 with
check uh Black's position is all ruined
and the white will of course win this
and another move after Knight E5 uh is
Knight to H5 this is the absolute top
move recommended by the engine going
after Knight to G3 uh but after Queen to
F2 you can just play Bop back to D6 and
the black consolidates for example Pawn
to F4 you play Queen to B6 you offer
Queen trade and if D4 stopping that now
you play captures on D3 alasa and after
a queen trade happens now Rook captures
on D3 white will be better but still
it's a playable position for black
however in the game she played Pawn to
C5 and now prog plays uh Rook H to E1
nicely piling up on the E file e
captures on F3 and now G captures on F3
uh even giving up frog uh giving up the
semiopen G file to prag so here we have
Knight to H5 uh but now Rook to G1 and
the big problem for Jun is that okay
prag didn't maybe play the absolute
strongest move here with Rook to G1 uh
A3 or queen to B5 are winning on the
spot uh but even this is uh pretty
strong as it's only move 24 and she's
only and she's already down to eight
eight minutes on the clock so here Pawn
to C4 giving up a pawn for some activity
on the queen side and now prog goes back
Knight captures on C4 also this uh makes
the Knight not so active as it is on E5
and it also opens up this e file
although there's not all that much that
she can do whatever she does there's
nothing to capture if if she captures uh
the Knight prog will just happily
capture with the queen and deliver check
so Queen to E7 is played and now Pawn to
A3 chasing away that bishop and there's
no good Square here like you go to C5 D4
is coming now you go to D6 for example
the Knight will happily capture it and
now even D5 and look at this it's uh
just really really bad for example
Bishop to F7 Queen to F2 and uh Prague
would be up to pawns uh also Prague
would be the one who's attacking and
usually you will have this um uh the two
Knight's attack uh the two knights
defense uh featuring the knight's attack
you will have black being down a pawn
but black will be the one who's
attacking black will be the one who has
active play and here prag is just up
material also with active play and you
know stuff to do so instead after A3 she
just captures on C3 we have Bishop
captures and now now Queen captures on
H4 grabbing a pawn here but now Queen E5
putting more pressure on that G7 Pawn
now the threat of course is the simple
Rook captures on G7 so Queen back to E7
she has to defend against Checkmate and
now Rook D to E1 just piling up on that
Bishop on E6 uh we have Queen to D7
unpinning and also uh you know maybe
looking for some counterplay on the
queen side uh but there's nothing you
can do Knight to D6 goes after The Rook
we have Rook to E7 and now Queen to H2
putting pressure on the knight uh only
Square for the Knight is the F6 square
and then of course Queen captures an H6
is coming so Knight to F6 was played
Queen captures on H6 and now Queen
captures on D6 proc played Bishop
captures on F6 and he was in this
position un move 33 that uh J engine
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so interestingly in
one event one classical event frog takes
down both world champions world champion
Ding and women's world champion Jun and
I don't know if that was uh ever
accomplished before maybe in uh uh you
know it's hard to say maybe in other
time formats but in classical I I can't
remember if you know as you know for a
very long time that that has happened
like even in the even in the olden days
but uh yeah I mean what do you know
since uh I don't remember a tournament
where someone defeated udit pogar and
Kasparov in the same event and also I
don't don't remember if anyone defeated
you know Magnus and the and the women's
world champion in the past 11 years so
yeah this could be this could very well
be the first time someone defeated uh
both Women's World Champion and World
Champion in a classical event yeah in in
in one tournament so you know big big
props to Prague for that and yeah he did
U drew a lot of games but victories
against the two world champions bring
him on top of the uh top of the
standings uh I'm just going to check the
standings real quickly as some of the
games are still being played and this is
one of the the crazier rounds almost all
of the games have been decisive very few
games ending in a draw uh but yeah as
I'm seeing yeah already on five and a
half we have Abdus satov giri prag and
GES so pretty pretty crazy stuff uh you
know no one no one really in the lead
everyone trying to be first and I mean
we're already in round nine it's still
possible for for pretty much anyone to
uh to win the tournament uh but yeah
sorry uh for for not mentioning why she
resigns uh what do you play here I mean
the uh this Pawn is just attacked three
times of course Rook captures on G7 is
coming next if you capture on F6 then
it's not a problem just Queen captures
on F6 and there's really I mean you have
nothing here even even if you get this
one check in h just King D1 and now you
have to go back you have to defend the
bishop but it doesn't work just Rook
captures and after Queen captures you
will play a rook cap on G7 with check
where she would have to choose between
giving up the queen or moving the king
and then it's just a nice checkm it this
way and if you don't do that if after
this um uh Bishop captures an F6 move
you somehow try to defend let's say you
play Rook F to F7 then you give up um
you have to start giving up material
Bishop Capt you're going to play uh rook
captur and now again Queen to F6 uh you
you you should have access to the A1
Square because if Queen captures some
Queen A1 action might be possible but
still you're you're just down material
you're down two pawns here you're down
in exchange here uh black is the one
under attack there's there is absolutely
nothing you can do here so of course
after Bishop captures an F6 and she was
already down to 30 seconds on the clock
and you'd have to make seven more moves
to reach time control uh she said enough
this game we'll try again uh tomorrow uh
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it the brilliant stuff by prog here he
is uh for the moment Untouchable he he
did have some issues in the previous
round but uh you know he was very solid
and was able to just Drew Drew draw the
game uh but yeah all in all Prague is
Prague is just a a monster a true beast
and uh he's uh will on his way to maybe
winning this tournament we'll see how it
goes uh so hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Len Herbert Yun young an
anonymous person ulam SE and Christopher
and Ruth brette for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your
day